aquí tenemos la gráfica de una función
exponencial y bueno esta función es m de
x y lo que quiero hacer es averiguar
cuánto va a valer m de 6 es decir quiero
saber el valor de m de 6 y bueno como
siempre te encargo que pause el vídeo y
veas si puedes resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno como mencioné ésta es una función
exponencial
entonces mx mx como es una función
exponencial va a ser de la forma a que
multiplica a r elevado a la x recuerdas
donde a es el valor inicial a es el
valor inicial y eren va a ser nuestra
razón común bueno el valor inicial
este valor que tengo aquí va a ser muy
sencillo de obtener será lo que vale m
de cero así que déjame anotarlo am a va
a ser igual al valor que vamos a tomar
en m de 0 en m de 0 y bueno para eso lo
que vamos a investigar es cuánto vale
nuestra función cuando x es igual a cero
y si lo vemos aquí en la gráfica cuando
x vale cero nuestra función toma el
valor de
9 por lo tanto va a ser igual a 9 a 0
que vale 9 muy bien ahora vamos a pensar
cuánto vale nuestra razón común y para
obtenerla no sé se me ocurre que podemos
hacer una tabla por aquí voy a hacer una
pequeña tabla por aquí
déjeme poner una recta por aquí muy bien
otra por acá muy bien de este lado vamos
a poner a equis de este lado vamos a
poner a equis y aquí a m de equis y
bueno que sabemos que cuando x vale 0 m
de x vale 9 es lo que nos dice el valor
inicial y que otro valor tenemos
bueno pues observa bien aquí cuando x
vale 1 cuando x vale 1 mpx toma el valor
de 3 de 3 por lo tanto ya lo tengo aquí
cuando x vale 1 m de equis vale 3
entonces cuando aumentamos x en uno
bueno qué pasó aquí de este lado
nosotros lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar
cuanto bueno para ir de 9 a 3 lo que
hicimos fue multiplicar por un tercio
está de acuerdo multiplicamos por un
tercio entonces esta será nuestra razón
común de hecho si quieres saber cuánto
vale m2
bueno pues habrá que multiplicar de
nuevo por la misma razón común que ya
sabemos que es un tercio y bueno tres
por un tercio es lo mismo que uno y lo
podemos verificar aquí cuando x vale 2 m
de x vale 1 te das cuenta entonces ya
podemos decir que nuestra razón común va
a ser igual a un tercio de lujo porque
ya con esto podemos escribir nuestra
función mx nuestra función
mx a quien va a ser igual bueno va a ser
igual a am pero sabemos cuánto vale
vamos a tomar el valor de 99 que
multiplica a la razón pero sabemos
cuánto vale esa razón esa razón vale un
tercio
un tercio está elevado a su vez a la
potencia x esto elevado a su vez a la
potencia x muy bien con esto ya tenemos
el valor de mx pero nosotros no
queríamos el valor de md x lo que
queremos es saber cuánto vale m de 6 así
que ya que tenemos a md x que te parece
si obtenemos a m de 6 y quien va a ser m
de 6 bueno va a ser igual a 9 por un
tercio elevado a la potencia 69 por un
tercio
terció esto elevado a la potencia 6 ok y
esto a cuánto va a ser igual bueno esto
va a ser lo mismo que 9 que multiplica a
1 elevado la sexta potencia pero bueno
eso es 1 entre 3 elevado a la sexta
potencia 3 elevado a la sexta potencia y
cuantos esto 3 elevado a la sexta
potencia am es lo mismo que bueno
esperar de hecho podemos simplificar un
poco porque puedes reconocer al 9 como 3
elevado a la segunda potencia y bueno
con esto podemos decir que esto es lo
mismo que 3 elevado al cuadrado entre 3
elevado a la sexta potencia y cuántos
esto bueno hay varias maneras de
atacarlo la primera que se me ocurre es
que podemos dividir tanto el numerador
como el denominador esto entre 3 elevado
al cuadrado
lo cual me va a dar
entre 3 elevado a la cuarta potencia o
dicho de otra manera también podemos ver
esto como 3 elevado a la 26
lo cual nos daría lo mismo que 3 elevado
a la menos 4 y bueno claro 3 elevado a
la menos 4
es lo mismo que 1 entre 3 elevado de la
cuarta potencia esto va a ser lo mismo
que 1 entre tres elevado la cuarta
potencia y cuanto se son tres elevado la
primera potencia es 33 elevado a la
segunda potencia es 93 elevado la
tercera potencias 27 y 3 elevado a la
cuarta potencia es 81 y ya está esto va
a ser lo mismo que 1 entre 81 así que ya
puedo decir que m de 6 es lo mismo que
uno entre 81 y bueno también pudimos
haberlo obtenido de esta tabla
pudimos haber dicho bueno si x vale 3 m
de 3 es lo mismo que si multiplicamos
por un tercio me va a quedar un tercio
si x vale 4 en vez de 4 haces lo mismo
que un tercio multiplicado de nuevo por
un tercio me va a quedar un noveno y si
multiplicamos de nuevo por un tercio me
va a quedar que en vez de 5 es lo mismo
que 1 sobre 27 y si multiplicamos de
nuevo por un tercio me va a quedar que m
de 6 va a ser lo mismo que 1 sobre 81